aux niches à quoi ça va pas d'un vous de
vous retrouver
je n'avais pas comme aujourd'hui
maintien c'est mignon tout ça au pied
c'est un tue-l'amour ton truc
concernant
je ne sais pas du tout
jours
qu'est ce que tu fais là je voulais
juste embrassés pas très adultes s'en
fout de notre gueule toi aussi tu penses
à charlotte est juste là à y passer vite
m
et de lune qui cite arrive tôt connard
je sais que certaines rencontres peuvent
mal tourner comme je sais que la
frontière est très fine entre le jeu de
la séduction et quelque chose pourquoi
pas de dangereux
je sais que j'attends quelque chose qui
arrivera pas moi j'avais des envies
immense avec toi comme jamais avec
personne
ce tuyau de mon mari je déteste le
mariage mais ce qu on se marie
c'est moi ça m'intéresse pas tiré des
coups dans la vie mais j'ai aucune honte
à dire que quand j'aime je peux faire
l'amour tous les jours sans même penser
que je le fais tous les jours tellement
jeune et tellement je fais ça comme je
respire